welcome everyone to the data science
hangout and welcome back to many of you
have joined us here in the following uh
past few weeks
but just for anyone who's new to this
and to joel thank you so much for
joining us this is an open space for
current and aspiring data science
leaders to just be able to connect and
ask each other questions and
really today joel we're excited to be
able to pick your brain a little bit
and so for the sessions we really want
to focus on any questions that are most
important to
you all here so you can jump in live or
put questions in the chat
and we also have a slido link which rob
will put in the chat window right now so
you can ask anonymous questions there
too
but just a little heads up that it will
be recorded for people that missed it so
it'll be shared up to youtube
but you always have that option of
anonymous questions as well
but i'm so grateful to be joined by my
co-host for today
joel pepera the director of data science
at geico and joel i'd love to have you
introduce yourself and maybe share a bit
about your team and the work that you do
sure absolutely and uh thank you for
having me i'm excited to talk to
everyone today um as rachel mentioned i
am the director of data science at geico
pretty much all of the data science
activities roll up through me we do have
other analytics teams and professionals
scattered throughout other parts of the
organization but
all the core data science work that we
do
falls under my purview
i've been at geico for quite a long time
uh coming up on 14 years
my professional background is primarily
in the actuarial space so i'm a
credentialed actuary which is an
insurance specific profession
that deals with a lot of things that are
say
similar to data science so using data
and predictive analytics and statistics
to
you know estimate things predict
values of interest and insurance it's
primarily
uh assessing uh customer risk uh so that
we could understand that from a pricing
and uh financial planning perspective
um
so that's what i did for most of my
early career and then about three or
four years ago
um pivoted into a broader data science
role
uh and we've been
building up our team and our
capabilities within geico
pretty aggressively
um at geico we focus on three main areas
of impact for data science
one is in our product development area
the second is in our customer experience
dealing with how we interact with
customers in marketing channels customer
service channels etc
and then the third major area is our
claims division
which deals with how we assess damages
and injuries
when people are involved in auto
accidents there's a lot of
interesting use cases there around fraud
detection or you know triaging
estimating payment amounts and things
like that
um use cases i think dealing with data
and statistics is not new but
certainly a lot of the um the
technological evolution going on not
just in insurance but but more broadly
is
causing us to think
a little bit differently
about things than we have in the past
and opens up a lot of really exciting
opportunities for us to
mature and move forward as as a as a
company
one of the primary areas that i'm most
excited about right now is um
is telematics
which for those who aren't familiar is
it's an initiative within insurance and
other industries as well where
due to you know the technology on modern
smartphones or increasingly technology
embedded in vehicles directly we can
with the customer's consent of course um
understand in a very detailed granular
way how our customers or potential
customers are
operating their vehicle and um get a
much
more granular assessment of the risk
profile so that's something that i think
in general is is a big focus for
companies in auto insurance and
certainly geico's among them so
there's a lot of really exciting
potential for data science in that
domain in particular
that's awesome and so the team's just
starting now to use telemat telematics
or how are you starting to do this today
uh yeah well i wouldn't say we're
starting we've been working with this
for a little bit now um it's not
i think a new phenomenon in insurance uh
some companies have been
at least in an r d capacity been been
working on this for for several years um
i think several market factors are
increasing the focus one is just the
technology is changing um smartphones
are obviously ubiquitous now and
that provides a cost-effective way of
collecting data i also think that um
consumer attitudes around privacy and
sharing data are evolving of course
there are still concerns and that that
will continue to be a factor but
you know i really think the pandemic has
impacted that
in some meaningful ways um you know
obviously when lockdown started
occurring uh people's driving behavior
changed and therefore their the risk
exposure changed and you know one of the
things we saw was people were realizing
you know my insurance rates aren't as
responsive as maybe they ought to be to
how
you know my use of my vehicle is
changing um and you saw a lot of
companies do some
um some large-scale measures you know to
provide people discounts or or
premiums and things like that but
i think it's also you know pointing to
an opportunity to just have
a pricing model that is in general more
responsive to how people are operating
their vehicle
and you know that kind of creates a
value proposition
that i think more people are are
comfortable with um in terms of
exchanging
you know some of their data for for that
value
and how how does the team or i'm just
curious myself how does the team get all
of that data or it seems like there's so
many different streams of data that
would be coming in
yeah it's a good question uh so
you pretty much have to have a
cloud-based approach here we're talking
about
sensor level data it's very large
volumes and we're talking petabyte scale
um really kind of depends on how many
customers and what your enrollment rates
look like but for us it's very large
um
uh so it's a significant data
engineering effort to
collect that data curate it um make it
ready for
you know applying models training and
and uh and inferencing on those
uh those data feeds so it's a big big
effort i would say it's
at least
as big on the data engineering side as
it is on the data science and
machine learning side so those those two
things go hand in hand i mean i think
that's true
in general with data science but in
particular um at the scale we're talking
that's a critical consideration
definitely i'm starting to see a few
questions coming in from
the audience and chris i see you just
asked
one in the chat do you want to ask that
live and introduce yourself
uh sure absolutely uh hello everyone i'm
chris schaible uh i have been doing
data analytics
for the past
24 years
active duty military retired and now got
myself slid into a data science role
so
some of the things that i'm trying to
get more
collective on besides
all the statistical stuff in that is
understanding more of the the tools
that my fellow data scientists out there
that are using
besides the fact of you know things like
python pandas
i know r studio is a big thing i'm
currently working
on
uh shiny applications where i'm at as
well but i was just kind of curious as
far as maybe some of the other tools out
there that that folks are using that i
might be able to to dive into and
utilize
yeah good question i think you uh you
listed off a lot of the key ones um you
know from uh certainly from a machine
learning
model training uh perspective r and
python are kind of the core languages um
our team
i would say mostly develops in python
but there are some um some users in
geico that are heavy r users as well
um so both of those i think are are
great languages to learn
um
you know sort of the dirty secret
although i don't think it's a secret
anymore about data sciences you spend a
lot of your time in data preparation um
so
i think the more adept you are with
languages like sql or
spark is a big one that we use a lot
just based on the scale of our data um
so learning uh
languages um like
scala uh
or you know the sql interface into spark
we often use uh pi spark pretty heavily
so
um
you know there are different interfaces
in the spark but just being comfortable
with optimizing data processing jobs uh
in a distributed setting i think is a
good investment of time
um for us it's mainly a combination of
spark and python
uh with
with a good good amount of sql as well
and then i think a lot of it sort of
depends on
you know beyond that which i think is
the core a lot of it depends on
what the role
of a data scientist is in a particular
company
and that can vary quite a bit
some of them find themselves more
um involved in some of the low-level
data engineering where you might want to
familiarize yourself with data ingestion
technologies you know kafka or
you know some of the streaming
technologies some data scientists tend
to find themselves getting more
um more involved in the front-end
development you know where they might
need to use
web development technologies javascript
uh those sorts of things so some of that
will depend on just where you're
situated in the overall kind of
development stack but
i would say spark sql and
python and are kind of the core
technologies that i would i would focus
on
thank you for that insight joel i
greatly appreciate that now that means i
can go ahead and add to my list of
things i need to start learning
that's good
as a um
i guess kind of a follow-up question to
that trevor i see you're asking around
how much time does the team spend doing
data analytics versus data science
trevor do you want to jump in and add
any context there
good morning good morning again we're i
mean our good afternoon depending on
where you are
um i'm just very curious you know the
field of data science continues to
evolve
i've seen so many definitions of data
science so many definitions of data
analytics
um
i think
the conclusion i'm working with in terms
of defining data science
is more around um building predictive
models i mean that's where i see the the
literature going towards so
i know
that not all the problems that we try to
solve in a company can be solved by data
science
some of it is actually analyzing basic
data
basic descriptions sarita wanted to find
out
most times when i talk to people on data
science teams i really want to find out
how much of their time is really spent
building fine-tuning and maintaining
models
as in data science versus trying to
answer answer everyday basic
questions yeah i think good question um
as you mentioned uh this can vary quite
a bit uh across different industries or
different companies within in the
industry and i think a lot of it depends
on the overall maturity of their
organization from a
sort of data and analytics perspective
at geico
we have a lot of
traditional analytics teams that will
apply statistical methods or
uh
various analytical techniques to derive
insights make recommendations to
some business consumers build reports
and those sorts of things um so at geico
our data science team
uh
tries to focus more on core data science
work which which i would consider to be
like you mentioned training predictive
models building machine learning systems
and
most of what we do like large-scale
systems that can
directly impact business processes
through some kind of production
implementation um so that i think for us
at least is the big difference the focus
on machine learning um
i think one differentiator i would also
draw is
our data scientists tend to be more
comfortable working with lower level
data or data in different formats
so not just
consuming data from databases but
getting into
semi-structured unstructured data being
able to
curate those views themselves clean the
data manipulate the data build features
out of it
most of the analysts we see
tend to be more comfortable
consuming data that's already been
uh
structured into a database
um and they're you know they're doing
more of the
kind of high level analysis on top of it
so that's another distinction i draw and
then i also think that um
the focus on putting code into
production
is something that data scientists tend
to do
more so than analysts so
you know building a model deriving
insights from it building reports
is
um important but there's sort of another
level of consideration when you have to
think about how a model is going to
interact in a production process
what data is going to be available
what's the context of a prediction
within a business process
how is the data going to be fed through
that model those are some really
important and and can be very tricky
considerations
uh that if you're not building models
for production you don't really have to
think about
um
so that's that's sort of how i think
about the distinction within geico that
said um you know these terms are fluid
across the industry what i described
in terms of data scientists like geico
you know another company might think of
as an ml engineer um
so
i think it's really important you know
if you're interviewing for a company or
considering different jobs to really
understand you know what is the role for
this person in this company regardless
of what the title is
and i feel like this this question of
like data analysts for data science
seems to come up in a lot of of
conversations as well and i know it
might be different for some larger
organizations versus
like smaller startups but would data
analysts sit on a much different team
than
than yours or do you have both data
analysts and data scientists um within
geico they're they're in a different
team but we would work collaboratively
collaboratively with them um so anytime
we take on a use case
uh we would typically identify partners
um on a business analyst team a business
process team
data engineering and if there's an
application team involved um
you know we sort of build these
cross-functional teams
uh to address a particular problem
i don't think that's the only model i
think a lot of companies combine them on
the same team and we've considered the
pros and cons of that
as well um so i think a lot of times
there's there's fluidity between the
roles um and especially at smaller
companies i think data scientists are
often
asked to wear many hats you know
just depending on what what that company
needs at the time you know maybe
maybe the best way to help them is by
creating a dashboard or
putting out some basic
summary statistics and analysis on that
i think a lot of data scientists have
run into and interviewing in just
different settings um
kind of get frustrated by that because
they come into the job the industry
thinking you know i'm gonna build
machine learning models or i'm gonna do
deep learning and um and i certainly
think it's important to find a role that
fits in with what you're looking for but
i would also stress that especially
early in your career
um being willing to kind of roll your
sleeves up and get involved in whatever
is needed is really critical and you'll
you'll develop a lot of good experience
through that as well so even if you you
know find yourself doing a lot of
low-level database work and you're not
really it's not really what you're
looking for long-term and i think
there's a lot of valuable learning to
that so you know i would certainly
encourage you to take advantage of those
opportunities and be flexible and
willing to
contribute value
however uh you can for the company that
you're working with
definitely thank you joel and i'm seeing
quite a few anonymous questions coming
in as well from slido and kind of going
back to what you were initially talking
about about things that changed during
the pandemic and
looking more into
or when people were driving less
did the pandemic force more data science
resources to be put into front-facing
customer experience initiatives
um
it's hard for me to say broadly i don't
that was certainly not the case at geico
or bigger organizations so we have more
specialization and teams that kind of
focus on
those aspects um
it definitely impacted us to a degree um
you know initiatives that we were
working on were maybe steered in a
direction that could directly contribute
to something more pandemic or like
related
um so i think there were some small
examples of that but i don't think it
was
a wholesale redirection of resources but
then within our company at least
i would strongly suspect that that
answer
would be different at other companies um
i think
in insurance we were certainly fortunate
to not be as directly impacted as some
other companies like
service industry for example hotel
industries there were huge impacts for
some of those areas and
um
and i expect the answer would be
different for people working there
thank you
um i'll jump back to a few of the
anonymous questions in a second here as
well but i see frank you weighed in in
the chat
um would you want to
jump in and ask that question live too
it's hard for me not to ask questions so
thank you
um joel i you got me really curious
talking about uh
data and models and then figuring out
how to give safer drivers better rates
it got my mind thinking again about
this is sort of a data governance
question
and
you could say you know what we're only
using the data for people that opt in
but sort of automatically by doing that
you're learning about the people that
don't opt in and i'm kind of curious
what do you what is your experience or
if you just had any comments or thoughts
on um what i see is sort of a moral
hazard there
yeah that's a great question uh
that's something
you know i think we had talked about for
years as
a complicated
sort of complicating factor for moving
forward with telematics if if it's a an
opt-in program you've got some
self-selection bias
and um you sort of have to think through
whether the economic incentives of that
align with your your business goals
um
i guess one thing i would say is uh
there are different ways of getting
telematics information
and
some of them have
higher adoption rates higher opt-in
rates than others so you know for
example one source is connected vehicles
and
people may or may not know this but you
know when you're at the dealership
buying a car and you're signing through
the million sheets of paper or whatever
one of those is is
in all likelihood opting into some sort
of monitoring for
for your driving behavior you know it
might be bundled in with some kind of
entertainment package or you know onstar
siriusxm or whatever um
so
you know there's some ethical
considerations there of course but that
also does kind of
um
shape a little bit of
the objectivity or the the
comprehensiveness of the data that you
have access to
um
to the larger question though i think
this honestly just has to
it's an evolving
picture right so initially you'll have
some limited adoption and you know your
data is biased by that but
um it's also the population that you're
trying to estimate right you're i mean
the way you're applying is the people
opting in so in some sense that is the
most relevant population to analyze but
that will evolve over time
um as there are other incentives for
people to kind of join the party and
contribute their data so i just think
you have to keep considering
the evolving profile people that opt in
and
you know i think the larger point in
this scenario and others is
making sure that there is a value to the
customer
so that it feels like a worthwhile
trade-off for them
um
you know people millions of people most
everyone has a smartphone these days uh
you're giving up a whole lot of data
just by owning that smartphone and you
know i think
some of the smartphone companies have
made a lot of progress in giving people
more control of what information they're
giving up which is important
but
uh and you do see uh
various levels of concern in backlash uh
in particular scenarios where
companies are misusing data but
overall i think a lot of people feel
like they're getting value out of
services like facebook or
youtube tick tock whatever
and um
you know as long as they feel like that
there's an equal exchange for what
they're giving up
i think people are increasingly getting
comfortable with that um
i don't know if that was a direct answer
to your question but it's not an easy
it's not an easy thing to consider but
it's an important thing when you're
doing practical data science practical
machine learning kind of think about
these second order effects of
um you know not only who is opting into
this but
what impact
does
my model
have an example right you come in with
some historical data about who buys what
products or whatever you build a
recommender system but that that system
itself is going to be biasing who
purchases what products and you know how
do you how do you plan for that bias
when you're trying to
um
you know retrain models or continue to
develop them
and prevent uh you know building echo
chambers for example so i think it
requires a lot of thought
a lot of it's use case specific but it's
a really important consideration for
people doing practical
data science work
yeah i think
you mentioned second and third order
effects that that's probably the more
interesting point because i think all of
the single applications
um
that
that we create and all the models that
we're building we could probably justify
each of them individually right there's
probably always a good reason and to be
honest the person that's driving 60
miles an hour down my residential street
i hope they're paying way more in cars
you should actually charge that person
more money
but um
yeah it's probably a matter of like the
micros are okay but then you put those
all together and you're like oh man
that's a
now we have a moral conundrum that we
need to deal with uh
more as an industry or society so i
appreciate it absolutely i think as a
data scientist you always have to be
considering the broader picture how is
my model going to be used
is that a valid use of the model given
what i know about the data that went
into it and how it was trained
um
i think there are a lot of pitfalls that
you know several people have pointed out
in recent years for misapplying models
so it's
definitely something that
data scientists need to be aware of um
coming to your point though about you
know incentives and making sure people
are um
being charged the right amount for how
they're driving i think one of the
the real true selling points about
telematics for insurance pricing is that
the user is in control
um and that wasn't always the case for
traditional characteristics that are
used to segment pricing
you know if you don't like the fact that
you're paying more because
you know you're driving 90 miles an hour
down the highway well you can change
your behavior and your price will adapt
and um
i think that is a satisfying realization
for people as well if you feel like you
have control and you understand
why you're paying what you are
um
you know there's there's sort of a
feeling of justice with that i think
i've been wearing i'll publicize the
woot band for the past few months
so it collects date on my heart rate
variability and it's it's awesome like i
feel like i am more control over
i don't know my my whole being
so yeah i fully agree
yeah i mean fitness monitoring is a huge
industry i i wear a garmin currently i'm
a runner and uh
you know it's just uh at least for a
certain type of person probably probably
a data scientist there's just a
fascination with collecting data on your
everyday life and just you know
analyzing your heart rate or your
sleeping patterns or movement and etc
i actually think that that's one
opportunity
for
for
expanding the use of telematics and
insurance you know
right now it's mainly seen as a
mechanism for giving you a discount but
um i think there might be a market for
applying some of the similar types of
insights that you get from your smart
watch to a driving context
that would be interesting to people and
also potentially help
coach them on how to develop safer
driving habits both for themselves but
also you kind of think through like a
teenage driver situation if you as a
parent have
more information
about how your teenage
children are driving you can have
better conversations with them about
encouraging safe habits and things like
that
i think about this a lot like all the
data that's out there about maybe from
oh there goes your lights
from like signing up from every
potential discount on every website or
like a
even electric toothbrush it's like
bluetooth enabled i'm like do i really
need that on the tooth
brush
um maybe shifting gears
maybe shifting gears a little bit i see
there's a question that came in around
does geico i.t centrally service all
data scientists across departments and
locations or do you have siloed
development in each group
um
i think it somewhat varies based on um
what you mean by it
so we we have different domains within
geico i mentioned kind of the three four
ones claims product and customer
experience um
from a customer interaction standpoint
and what we think of as our front-end
applications that deal directly with the
customer those are
um segmented teams
that sort of own their applications uh
when it comes to more of the back end
development like data engineering
cloud infrastructure and that those
sorts of components those are more
centralized and we work with
you know the same team that kind of
serves the needs across those different
domains so it kind of depends on
you know what part of the data science
pipeline we're dealing with
and i guess kind of on a similar related
thread there's an anonymous question on
do you need a big budget to support data
science properly
boy uh depends on what you mean by big
budget and i guess what you're trying to
accomplish this is being recorded don't
lie
uh
for what we're trying to do i i would
certainly characterize the budget is
fairly large um
you know data scientists are an
in-demand
skill set and uh you know you need to be
competitive to attract top talent
um
and then there's also there can be big
infrastructure costs
especially when you're talking about
you know petabyte scale data both in
terms of storage processing
requirements and so forth so that is
definitely a big investment um
not every company has the scale of data
or the same needs as we do
so if you're just trying to gain
insights or you know build
higher quality reports
you know i would think
the bart entry is a lot lower
not sure there's a single answer but
yeah i think for me yes the uh
it's a significant budget item
i see steve playing in the chat you need
the biggest budget yes
it's not untrue
you know if you're if you're a startup
and you're not direct and you're not
like a direct technology play that like
inherently requires
machine learning
this is probably not like the best
initial investment for you um
so
yeah it's a big investment
if you are in that position or maybe
comparing like a huge company like geico
and building out that data science team
to a startup what do you think that
startup should
focus on initially with building out
data science
well
data science really relies on a solid
foundation of data engineering so i
would say you know if you if you think
data science or machine learning is
eventually going to be a big
contributor to your bottom line
getting really good
at collecting and organizing data
is a great place to start because
i think
some companies who haven't really
dealt with that fundamental
infrastructure
you know hear a lot about all the cool
things that data scientists are doing
you big technology companies or you know
internet companies and they think oh i'm
just going to hire a bunch of data
scientists and
i'm going to be able to do all these
like really exciting things and
what that often leads to is a frustrated
data science team because they find out
that
the data they need is scattered across
dozens of different databases and
different environments different formats
and that's where they end up spending
all of their time pre-processing and
you know building databases just before
they can even
get to
uh delivering insights or building
models so
i think thinking through your data
architecture and your data strategy
early on is is pretty critical in my
view
could could you maybe define like levels
of data science maturity for companies
ah it's a good question
um i would say
probably the level one is
you've got one maybe a couple data
scientists and
you're really just looking for them to
derive insights this is probably a
company that
doesn't have a lot of existing analytics
support you know
they're they're making decisions based
on
experience or domain knowledge or
you know things like that and they
really don't have a data-driven approach
at all and so they hire data scientists
and they say well you know
what
what what does the data say about the
decisions i'm trying to make how can i
uh improve upon
you know a very heuristic based
decision-making process there i think
you know the bar is pretty low
you could
use a basic data set some pretty basic
um modeling techniques and probably
improve upon what they're doing um
and from there i mean there's sort of
almost infinite stages in between all
the way up to you know
it's very machine learning driven where
they've got hundreds of models that are
running that determine pretty much every
aspect of how the customer is
interacting uh with their systems you
know from recommender systems to fraud
detection
to
uh all kinds of personalization
opportunities uh
sorry i'm looking at the chat with the
accountable infinite versus uncountable
infinite sages fun fact when uh when i
was uh doing my graduate work i actually
studied mathematical logic and set
theory so
uh
i could speak
at length about that question in
particular but that's probably not as
relevant to the conversation but um
anyway to the original question and the
point i think there's just
a huge spectrum in between and it really
depends on what the business goals are
data maturity and so forth i'd say geico
is somewhere in between those two
extremes you know
um probably further toward the the
mature
uh data science organization um but
you know probably not as
as mature as a company like netflix or
amazon or uber or something like that
thank you and uh apology was my internet
cutting out for just a second but there
was a slight
delay there
um
but i see that trevor you asked a great
question in the chat as well
come on in cover
yeah sorry sorry so so
sorry it was my internet there it gave
me the unstable notice yeah no no
problem no problem um
this question is a really really really
important question to me because
the the models that we build
we don't just build them in our lab
right they impact lives
you know they impact lives so
so essentially in this case
the whatever the model predicts is
impacting for example i'm assuming the
rate that someone pays
um for insurance
right so
[Music]
so how do you know that your model is
actually making the right decision and
so so that's key for me because i guess
i'm from jamaica um i'm a person of
color and i've read
many cases where
there are models that
don't behave as though i would want them
or all they should
and the impact on people's lives is
negative so i just wanted you know some
insight into that if you don't mind yeah
it's a great question um
so i'll answer kind of the general
question of you know how do you know
your models are working and then um you
know i think there was certainly a
ethical ai component to your question
too which we can talk about um
in general uh when you're when you're
evaluating a machine learning system i i
think of three levels of monitoring um
one is
the
sort of infrastructure monitoring the
technical system monitoring you know
this is a piece of software it's a you
know maybe a web service or whatever and
you need to
you need to understand um how that
system is performing and making sure
that um you know it's able to handle the
volume of requests that are coming into
it um
you're not seeing you know
large error rates things like that so
there's a sort of low level technical
monitoring that's important
then there is what i would call
statistical monitoring which is
is the model
reliably predicting what it was trained
to predict you know are the or the
distribution of the feature inputs
changing over time is the distribution
of score changing over time you know
that's i think a very important
diagnostic to understand whether it's
time to retrain your model because you
see drift
um
or you know whether there's some change
in the population
um that's being scored through your
model
those are really important and then
there's the third which i think gets
closer to what you're asking about which
is
what are the downstream business impacts
of the prediction so
you know you're predicting whatever it
is that you're trying to predict but
then there's often actions that are
taken based on that prediction and
typically there are business kpis or or
maybe other considerations um
that are associated uh with those
actions and so we would typically set up
monitoring uh for some of those things
as well and i think it's important to
have all three levels um to your point
about um you know how models impact
people's lives and you know how they
might disparately impact certain groups
over others i mean it's
a very important and um
i think a field that's or a topic that's
getting a lot of um
consideration
uh over the recent months and years um
personally i don't think there's an easy
answer to it um
i think it requires
an investigation of specific use cases
you know how the model interacts with
different groups of people what is the
intended impact versus what the actual
impact is
um you know so for example um so there's
a lot of talk about ai bias and you know
how predictions skew toward one group or
another
um
and you know one answer might be
saying well we don't we don't want there
to be any skew across certain
demographic groups um
but i think
and i understand what's behind that i
think in some cases that might be the
answer
but i also think in some cases that's
not really the intent you know if you
think about for example a product
recommendation
engine
and something like gender
i think a lot of people would expect and
would want there to be some bias and
product recommendations across gender
but in some cases they might have
problems with certain recommendations
being targeted at one gender or another
so
there's some nuance there and it's hard
to s to set a global policy that i think
covers all cases
um
so again i think it's one of those
things that a data scientist needs to be
aware of they need to know how their
model is going to be used and they need
to
ensure that that is consistent with the
data that's being fed into it
and the methodology that's used to make
those predictions
i know in um i think it was a meet-up
talk with aetna insurance they talked a
little bit about or cvs health
um talked about an ibm ai fairness 360
app that they use um and maybe another
one that google had come out with
does geico use something like that
internally
um
we do not use one of those specific
model or those specific um tools
we do have a process for evaluating the
fairness of our models
um
don't know that i can get into the
specifics of it but it is certainly
something we considered
yeah definitely thank you
when they're i'll just jump in real
quick as a follow-up question when there
is discomfort around let's say um
targeting a certain segment with a
certain product
how does that decision get uh
worked through i imagine it's the uh
sort of leadership team's responsibility
yeah certainly um
uh leadership is responsible for making
the ultimate call there
certainly consult a legal counsel
um consider the you know the business
impact the ethical impact and things
like that so it's
um
do we handle those on a model by model
basis
but you know ultimately it's
leadership's call
um there's quite a few anonymous
questions still here so
um i'm hoping we can go over the time
just a little bit here
but one is with a large data science
team how do you balance the needs for
structure like same language same coding
standards et cetera burst the needs for
speed to produce a result
it's a good question um
so the way we approach we i mentioned we
had sort of three domains and those
more or less operators autonomous teams
um
but we do
coalesce around languages and
um
some of the primary tools um
i don't really see that as an impairment
for speed to market or development speed
um
you know
i don't i don't see you know setting up
standards around uh how we're going to
structure our data our code repositories
or you know that we're all going to use
python we're all going to use
um you know data bricks as our park the
spark development environment i don't
really see those impediments as
impediments to speed
um
so i'd be curious to know what what the
uh
the questioner
has in mind or what their experience is
in terms of like standards getting in
the way of
speed to market
i'm not sure that we'll get additional
contacts just because it was an
anonymous question but
i am curious so on that first part of
the question so the need for structure
like how do you handle that with teams
using r or python or other languages
does that matter
well i mean within my team we're we're
pretty consistent with
what tools we use it's pretty much a
python and spark shop
i would say it probably so
we don't collaborate as directly with
some of the other teams in geico that
use
r i suppose that down the line if we
wanted to go there just because
the code's different
i don't know that those things aren't
overcomeable but it would certainly be
a little bit um
a little bit longer to kind of get up to
speed on either side uh because of that
like language difference um it's just
really not a problem that we've run into
so far
i know your team mostly uses python but
i see ethan just asked a question um if
data science teams at geico use sas
hi ethan if it's the ethan kang i'm
thinking i think we have a professional
connection in the past so if that's true
nice to
speak with you again but um uh to answer
your question no we do not
uh
when i review resumes we occasionally
see that um but i
at least for the candidates that we
review that's
sort of becoming
a dated language that i don't think a
lot of people focus on
and even if you talk to people at sas i
think
they're increasingly looking to support
open source languages like r and python
even within their platform so
that's kind of how i see it
ethan did you want to jump in and weigh
in there
yeah hi joe nice to see you again good
to see you
yeah so when i was at geico um
in the actual department we all used sas
so it was just curious how
how if they at data science team they
use that as well but
yeah i mean there are certainly other
groups within geiger that use sas um
i think
i think as a company even we're starting
to move
more and more away from that i mean you
know you build up code bases over years
and years i i don't
it would be difficult to i think
completely abandoned that but for a lot
of the new development we do certainly
within the analytics space that
it's not centered around sas
thank you nick i see you asked a
question around sharing data sets would
you want to weigh in and uh jump in and
ask that
sure i work for a um
a
company where we don't even share data
between divisions but i was wondering
you know with with geico you know being
part of berkshire hathaway and and
really probably an organization that
uh
definitely thinks about the different
parts of its business is there any
sharing or anything like that or is that
even on a road map
um
it's like sharing data or maybe just the
infrastructure between between different
subsidiaries or
uh
yeah is it something that i'll ever talk
about
that's a good question um
there are some cases where
there's
sharing of information across mercury
subsidiaries so it does happen but
um by and large the way berkshire
operates
is they leave their subsidiaries largely
autonomous and they sort of function as
independent companies to a large degree
again not going to say that there isn't
some coordination but
it's really not part of the day-to-day
and
not the typical way we operate so
infrastructure for example
i don't even know what cloud
infrastructure or infrastructure
otherwise
you know other companies in the
berkshire portfolio use we don't share
that across at all
so maybe not as much as you would think
but and honestly if you kind of look
look at what warren buffett and others
in the berkshire circle say i mean they
explicitly acknowledge that they like to
keep
their part or their subsidiary companies
more or less autonomous and
self-sufficient
similarly to the data that you're using
and sharing it among teams there was an
earlier question on if geico
utilizes data from public safety
answering points or emergency
communications
looks safety so
like uh not not quite sure what we're
referring to there um
like public service announcements or
like
not quite sure public records yes i'm
wondering if it's like uh
i can only guess what their
question is about but around like 9-1-1
records or oh i see
uh no not in general
uh i'm actually not
totally sure what's available um in that
regard or what information we get um we
definitely have access to
outside data um
things like police reports or public
records data that
has
application in different different
domains within geico but
i'm not aware of any
usage of
911 data or anything like that
okay
um and shifting gears a little bit i
know you mentioned geico is hiring and i
think i saw linkedin roles working with
telematics data um but as you're
starting to evaluate candidates i'm
curious what experience are you looking
for
[Music]
what are those roles
so we
are interested in hiring across the
spectrum
and certainly bringing in uh
more experienced candidates that could
come in at a senior level is a big focus
but we're also interested in people who
are
just entering the data science
profession
um you know we look for people who
have
a pretty solid understanding of machine
learning fundamentals so they're
familiar with various algorithms to kind
of understand
how they work what some of the major
you know hyper parameters are and how to
tune them and what some of that stuff
means um that's i think a pretty
fundamental requirement
um like people to have some experience
in working with different data sets um
whether it's just you know sql
experience or to have
experience working in
big data ecosystems that that would be
great as well
um
beyond that i honestly i think it's just
really important to have
candidates who are enthusiastic
able to think through and solve problems
in efficient ways
so even if you don't have
you know five years of experience
developing in spark or python but you
have some baseline knowledge of that and
you know you're really eager and
enthusiastic to learn
and you've got
a good sense about data and
you're able to frame
analytical questions well and you know
create data products that answer those
questions um
that those are sort of the core skills
that we look for
um i'll say most of the people even at
the entry level that we bring in do have
some sort of advanced degree in
some stem related
field
and that could vary quite a bit honestly
i mean
i think there
are
an increasing number of data analytics
or data science programs at the master's
level in particular but you know we've
also brought in some pretty strong
candidates who
have phds in physics or theoretical
chemistry or
i mean even as diverse as like music
history um so i don't necessarily think
there's one path into data science
and we consider candidates with a
diverse range of backgrounds
great
frank i see you had a great question
earlier that i want to make sure we get
to
around decision making um would you want
to jump in and ask that one
uh sure i'll try to do it um quickly so
it's related to your your three
buckets of monitoring or when trevor
asked how do you know if your models are
working or right
and you had mentioned that
in that last that third bucket
we set up monitoring for for those
things as well and i found it very
challenging you can make predictions
statistically like your bucket number
two hey things are all good these are
good predictions you should use them to
make decisions
trying to capture
when those predictions are used as an
input to the decision
um
some i find that sometimes naturally it
can happen where there's a system where
there's a record but most of the time
it is very hard to tell if the
predictions are being used
um
i come from retail i'm in the supply
chain world a lot of what we do is still
manual maybe it's different in your
world and so i'd like to hear about that
yeah no it's an important point i think
the stronger the connection to the
between the model prediction and the
action the easier it is to measure but
that's not always the case i mean
sometimes
you're providing guidance or
recommendations and it's still
ultimately up to
the decision maker to factor that in
along with you know many other things
and so attributing
a specific action to the model can be
difficult um
i don't know that there's a an easy
answer to that all the time some of that
can be handled though through
good experimental design so
you know maybe
you know in your case in retail maybe
there
there's a way of only rolling out a
product in a subset of stores and then
you compare that to the stores where
it's not so even
if you get those stores
had access to that prediction and this
other group didn't and you hope that
through your experimental design you
randomized enough uh for some of the
other uh confounding factors and you're
able to draw
valid inferences about the impact of
that um so i think you just have to
think through the experimental design
how you're going to measure that um
keeping in mind
just what the business case is and how
the
prediction is being used yeah for sure
do does your team
are there did they do anything are they
responsible for that is there another
team that uses your models and then does
the experimental design
um yes some of that varies by use case
uh
and
you know frankly the capability and
skill set of the teams that we're
partnering with and some of them have
you know pretty good analysts that are
good at
you know designing uh how we're going to
measure the impact and they're able to
drive some of that reporting independent
of us
in some cases we have to take on more of
that as well
um
so it really just kind of depends
for sure
laughing at the helmet trevor i guess
that's
uh it's ultimately a good measurement
right
joel how does your team help other teams
in geico improve their knowledge and
skills and data science
question um
i don't think we have explicit
mechanisms for that right now um you
know we don't
have
trainings that we leave for other
analyst groups might be something we
consider as as we kind of expand our
organization
um but most of that happens i think
within the context of product teams
you know we're just by the nature of you
know needing to communicate results or
communicate how things work to
a team that's going to consume the
outputs you have to explain how these
things work how you should interpret
them you know what does precision mean
what does recall mean
how do these features react to the
target or stuff like that so it's i
would say more informal
typically
at least the way that we operate
i mean aside from training do you have
some sort of like internal
community or group where people share
different things that they work on or
like a slack channel for people help
each other
yeah so um
we use webex teams which is sort of a
slack clone i guess um
or like microsoft teams very similar uh
that's something that we really
adopted during the pandemic and i think
it's actually been a great addition to
our workflow
uh so we definitely uh communicate a lot
through that and share information um
through different teams channels um
so that's a good avenue
within our data science organization we
have
regular team meetings where different
teams are sharing what they're working
on
we often
you know get access to different
vendor products that you know we'll
organize different calls around so
there's some information sharing there
uh you know attending conferences
um
so i guess there's a lot of different
mechanisms where people sort of share
information or get information from
outside groups
um
that we have available at geico i
probably take some of that for granted
just having always worked at a big
company with a lot of resources um
i think it's it's hard for me to sort of
appreciate how that might not be
available at a smaller company
yeah i can imagine there's
quite a large group of of data
scientists there
yeah i mean so another example is um you
know within our larger department that
we sit within you know everyone has
access to a coursera subscription you
know there's tons of resources available
there to learn
whatever you're interested in so that's
an example
nice as we're all kind of thinking about
some of the use cases at geico
um i see
someone asked a question do you have any
public facing applications or is
everything that's built only internal
uh
public facing well uh
i would say yes maybe not directly but
through an integration with one of our
front-end applications
and so if you
log into geico.com and you try to get a
quote
you know we would have some technology
that's
impacting that experience or if you're
if you're a customer and you're
submitting a claim
we would have technology that would
impact your experience there so maybe
not directly but certainly
through those application integrations
awesome
and i know as we get to the top of the
hour here i just want to ask you joel if
people have other follow-up questions or
want to connect with you what's the best
way to get connected is that linkedin
yeah linkedin would be great um feel
free to uh you know send a connection
request send me a message whatever be
happy to follow up and talk to you about
what we're doing at geico or provide any
you know advice based on my experience
and you know working in data science
feel free to reach out
great thank you joel and one other
question i i wanted to ask is i know
there's a bunch of people on the call
who may be aspiring data science leaders
and
what feedback would you or advice would
you give to someone hoping to move into
a leadership role
uh
really pay attention to the business
right because ultimately you're there to
drive business results and
you know the technology the
methodologies the statistics and data
science are really interesting you can
dive as deep as you want in in that area
and have a great career
and be fulfilled in that area but if you
want to move into leadership you need to
learn to
speak
the business language
understand the needs of the business
that you're trying to serve
and you know through that i think you
can be an effective leader and just
understand how to bridge the gap between
the technology
and the business process that can
leverage that technology because a lot
of times
i mean that that's honestly a very
valuable skill because a lot of people
are good at the technical side they can
you know tell you how machine learning
algorithms work and how to optimize you
know the different parameters to predict
the value but they can't really relate
to the business problem and then on the
other side
there's a lot of business leaders who
have
a very high level understanding of
machine learning or ai they've read you
know harvard business review or
something like that but they don't
really
understand it in meaningful terms so
being someone who can bridge that gap i
think is a great way to advance into
leadership within data science
wonderful and and i completely agree
with jeffrey who just said can you clip
that
thank you thank you so much joel
i want to just open the
open it up to any other questions or
anything that i have potentially missed
i'm trying to read through all the
the questions on slido too
so feel free to jump in if there are any
final ones
so i had a last question this is trevor
again um
joelle do you
[Music]
so you know
as a leader right um do you still get
time
or do you think it's necessary and i
know it depends on
the whole
large or small
or the organization
is but do you actually get time to
travel i think the wi-fi dropped for
just a second there
you want to ask
i think i maybe see it in the i can see
it in the chat too
trevor asks as a leader do you still get
time to devote to actually building
models
um so at my level i don't do any of that
professionally i really just don't have
the time um sometimes in my free time uh
you know i'll actually i'm currently
taking a corsair course right now so i
you know i can work that in sometimes in
the margins but professionally honestly
just
don't have the time for it um
so that i mean that's i think one of the
choices you make
when you decide to go into data science
leadership versus you know being a
senior technical contributor or
something like that is you you you
recognize that your hands on time is
going to diminish the higher that you
advance
but i think it's important to
invest enough in at least understanding
the technologies i mean data science is
a rapidly developing space
technologies platforms tools
methodologies are always moving i think
as a leader you need to invest enough of
your time to understand how to make good
decisions
um in your job and how to utilize those
technologies where to invest and those
sorts of things
um to do that well so you can't
completely you know
ignore
what's going on i think you have to
maintain some connection
um
to some of the lower level details um so
it's a balancing act
thank you joel and i know we are a
little bit past the hour so there's a
few other questions but i want to be
conscious of your time too so see if you
have a few more minutes you have to run
i do have to run unfortunately um but
like i said if you want to follow up
with me on linkedin i'd be happy to you
know extend the conversation there
awesome well thank you so much joel for
your time really appreciate all the
insights and
hope hopefully we'll see you back on one
of these in the future too
thank you so much for joining
you